this show is brought to you by mana calm
go to on intercom and use code word
Church to get 10% off of all the great
supplements alpha brain ooh mood soon
tech community export Joey uses a strong
bone a lot check it out use code word
Church and get 10% off also go to hit
ecigs comm that's hit the letter e cigs
calm better tasting longer-lasting
the proof is in the vape they have each
cigarettes and e cigars for you if
you're looking to quit smoking in the
new year or tone it back they have
different levels of nicotine so you can
go from 24 down to 16 8 hopefully down
to 0
hit ecigs the Cobras Joey's church and
you're gonna get 20% off go to nailed it
life calm for the premiere favorite
print on the market for all you aisle
and whack smokers out there when you go
to nailed it life calm checkout they
have t-shirts they have a bunch of
awesome products but their best product
the product you want is their vapor pen
works with oil and wax use codeword Joey
Diaz and you're getting a 20% off and go
to new iron dragon TV calm and use
codeword Joey to get two free rentals
they have the it man series they're
gonna have 4k technology soon and on
January 7th at 2 p.m. at the CES booth
for nanotech iron dragon TVs parent
company booth one five four two three
Tim Kennedy is gonna be signing photos
signing autographs and taking pictures
[Music]
it's addictive oh [ __ ]
Oh what oh [ __ ] will bat [ __ ]
January's big Oh another winter sound of
the funky drummer get up wash your [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's a whole new year I
don't want to hear you [ __ ] grind
again this is your year from the start
it starts today [ __ ] what Oh
what we got the fight the power that
beat get up the power is you fight that
[ __ ] wash that [ __ ] watch that
[ __ ] out of them balls got your shoes
wash your teeth comb your hair get out
there to church [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is going on get up you filthy
[ __ ] Happy New Year 2015 or in
reality it's just another day and you
got a [ __ ] job to do get the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] write your goals
it starts today you're gonna quit
smoking you're gonna do this
you ain't gonna [ __ ] blow kids behind
the [ __ ] amusement park no more it
all starts [ __ ] today [ __ ]
it's a new year that's it these
[ __ ] make it a new day it's a
new day it's a new Daniel getting a
second [ __ ] chance the Church of
what's happening now what's up you bad
[ __ ] you you okay but here
fired up I gotta be got to be it's a
whole new [ __ ] in I gotta let these
people know that that's it the [ __ ]
game is over you've been putting [ __ ]
off for too long and that's it I'm
excited it's a [ __ ] whole new year
whole new set of rules I love it again
it kind of hit me this year for the
first time I'm like wait it's just
another day tomorrow doesn't feel any
different no difference it's amazing
when you wake up New Year's Day and like
you think like nothing as a kid I used
to I'm still that same ugly [ __ ] at the
7-eleven trying to get a nickel from you
in a wheelchair with a sign you know
there's still every [ __ ] day there's
something every day every day you're
hustling
your weekend it was great well I ran I'm
trying to do things that are against my
grain absolutely so I went to the gym
Apollo on Friday and we got that Lake
which we got delivered them we wanted to
but we walked in and Eddie was walking
down any bar was walking down the stairs
so went up and said hi and he's with
this dude I didn't I didn't know who he
was and he introduced himself he was
Dallas Page the wrestler and ever since
I've been working out him before then
people have told me tried DDP yoga tried
DDP yoga it was on Shark Tank a couple
years ago I mean I only the only times
I've done yoga were a couple times I did
the hut the rec room with my dad and I
hated it because it's like 110 degrees
it's terrible oh I didn't like it so I
went to the store that night and he
emailed me he was just like hey nice to
meet you
if you're interested for you and your
friend I'm doing a seminar tomorrow I'd
like to give you guys two free passes
everything in my system doesn't want to
do that early in Hollywood which is
alive 11:00 but we had to go to yoga man
so we woke up at 8:30 which isn't that
early but on the Saturday going to
Hollywood it's not something I really
want to do ever especially not to work
out for three hours but it was free and
we just were like [ __ ] it so we did it
when I woke up it at a thought like oh
maybe not but we just we just did it
went down there there was like 50 people
in like a gym in a Hollywood Park down
there on Beverly and he did about two
hours hour and a half of motivational
stuff pretty cool stuff he didn't even
start wrestling till he was like 35 or
professionally and he did about an hour
and a half of it got progressively
harder yoga it was a lot of cardio stuff
and it was a lot of he was wanting to be
clenching just to engage the muscles I
didn't sweat as much as I do on the
elliptical but you've been on me for a
while to do a class so like [ __ ] I I
just something it was like I was like
how many people out there would want
it was an expensive class it was like an
$80 class like he's giving it to me for
free I'm my why wasted why stay at home
and just sleep a little bit later so I
thank you very much that's uh that's
something that I don't learn in the hard
way you know going out of your comfort
comfort zone for anything when you go to
school to be an attorney that's Paula
once you got into law school Shan do a
bunch of math classes but you've been
curriculum for attorney you ask yourself
why do I have to take this math to be an
attorney for you analytical so to get
you thinking right and this is all I
love this I've always loved this I love
going out of my comfort zone
I really don't but I do yeah you think I
wanted to get on that plane to Vegas on
Friday nope no I've been home for
[ __ ] three weeks I have not seen a
[ __ ] plane on airport
my mind was somewhere else and I was
thinking of canceling the flight like
canceling the day they in flight to
Vegas and going it to and going to the
wayans and all this [ __ ] I got up that
morning I said [ __ ] I'm gonna go you
know and as soon as I got off the plane
and got to the Vegas I mean there was
traffic you know there was a taxi
traffic like there was it was back the
Vegas was [ __ ] back that's cool I get
to the hotel I go upstairs it's always
the last [ __ ] hotel room on the aisle
you know he was talking about we we
exercise in Las Vegas just by [ __ ]
walking yeah I go to the end of the to
the thing and I got stairs and I meet
Ari
you know awesome any anxiety I had one
away that was one of the best day trips
I've had in years that I really needed I
even I get comfortable man yeah and
sometimes you go outside your realm and
you bump into something a part of you
you bump into a different party while
you're there and it wakes it up you know
wastes a monster inside of you right and
maybe you won't go back to that place
maybe you'll never do DDP yoga again but
you're gonna get something out of it
yeah you're gonna get there now you did
it I did it
there's no you walk into these places
I'm insecure so as soon as I walk in I
feel embarrassed I'm the fat guy in the
[ __ ] old Paul and I were worried
about yeah we walked in and there were a
bunch of douche bags you know with tight
suits on and there was that many suits
there was a lot of having people there
that we weren't even we weren't even the
best people by far there was one couple
people who look like it was a New Year's
resolution and I'm so glad this wasn't
my first time working out because I
wouldn't have made it through it but I
didn't have to take a break because he
they they all said look you can take a
break if you want to I couldn't do
everything like I have horrible balance
so I kept falling down when I tried to
do the pose but you do like we have to
look straight ahead you have to pick the
spot nice it's like the core it's the
core yeah yeah so I I didn't get to do
everything probably perfectly but they
had people walking like his fiancee was
walking around in he she she showed me a
couple things and it was cool it was
cool to stretch like I stretched
something like a can opener
where you like dragged your leg across
in front of you while you're laying down
you're like you brought eat you're happy
yeah it was cool see every before I do
anything I always lay on my back and get
my ass and I put it up against the wall
and I kicked my legs up I let the blood
go down and then and I breathe and I
straightened my feet out to stress the
back of your legs and I stretched my
arms I'm like Jesus Christ right yeah
and ice to do that I let the blood go
down my heart pump all that [ __ ]
unsolicited blood then I twist while I'm
breathing to my left and I have my wife
pull my shoulder down and pull my head
down as I breathe it's tight but the
more you breathe don't Lucy you'll get
again you pick your legs up to the
middle breathing the whole way up and
then I go to the other side you follow
me and that stretches that core you know
yoga the tremendous moves all right if
you haven't tried yoga because of an ego
problem or whatever [ __ ] problem you
have you're really missing the boat I
had a problem with yoga I didn't know
what it was so again I was like anybody
else in this country anybody else in
life if you don't know what something is
you're very tuned off to it yeah I don't
want to do that the first time my wife
took me every day when I wake up I'm
like [ __ ] I should go do yoga today
after why I looked at the schedule it's
weird like today it's 11:45 I thought
about it I really have plans my wife
goes to Zumba Monday 15 at the white a
beautiful [ __ ]
they have one outdoor yoga here in town
they have a lot of I mean if you go up
and down Burbank Boulevard Magnolia
Boulevard in the valley this tons of
yoga Apple yo I mean there's tons of the
place by Laurel Canyon that my friend
works this if you want to go in there
that's right I don't know if you know
which one I'm talking about right down
the block from the house if you hit
Magnolia when you go to right back oh
yeah pies chicken yeah right there next
to it yeah my friend Lee she's a Cuban
girl that's Cuban Jewish girl
oh I opened you from Miami she runs the
family I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to do it but my goal is 300 or 365 do
something work out wise I don't know if
I'll be able to be the gym every day but
like I figured that's that's one day off
a week plus 13 bonus days I don't know
if I'm gonna hit it but that's my goal
that's your goal listen I wrote my you
know you have a personal your personal
goals your business goals you have you
know physical goals you know I like to
lose eighty [ __ ] pounds I write that
and then you write how can I do that by
maintaining my eating by keeping a log
by walking with mercy this works that's
working for me this is the first time
this is working for me first of all I
haven't really I've got to do two
techniques I haven't really rolled okay
because I do something after did you
technique class I do a bunch of
calisthenics with this guy and then I
cut my workout down believing that I was
overdoing it is the law of diminishing
returns I was walking around so I went
back to the old reliable the bicycle my
wife taught me a long time I don't know
why you started working out the fat came
off with the bicycle on the punching bag
came off well the last thing you're
doing this and this and this you made it
more complicated than what isn't I have
totally I we did that with food like we
used MyFitnessPal and it's great but it
Lord meter 1,400 calories and loaded
Laura Paulette to 1212 1220 and we were
just talking to people and there's
something called a BM are not BMI like
tells you how fat you are but BMR or is
like how many calories your body needs
so they have this formula where it's
like that plus your workout calories
- 500 so now I get like 1,900 calories
and I have I haven't had this much in
months and I've been losing weight it
says like your body kind of shuts off
when you don't have enough which I knew
but I didn't think the man I was having
was shutting it off but I lost weight
like three days in a row I'm still I'm
almost back to my lowest I'm pretty
happy sometimes you know especially
going to Hollywood like if I gotta drive
the Hollywood the whole dry I didn't
have to drive to the whole Drive I'm
talking myself out of it yeah the whole
driving will go on boy I wish somebody
runs a red light it's this [ __ ] car
Simon excuses you don't want cause I'm
gonna say you got into an accident you
have that hanging over your head you
know yeah but that it's great it's great
when you get out of we've discussed this
a thousand times on here that's a great
way to start the year because you got
someone coming like I didn't want to do
it I think I was like maybe I won't even
tell Paulo about the offer and she was
kind of an by but what we're gonna do on
Saturday morning what's the point of
wasting it you know man this is
something you have to do every day that
I didn't think elected in the early yeah
I didn't think that's an early age and
neglected at 28 I thought my body would
stay away and always been I thought that
what people were saying to me we're
lying they're all lying
your metabolism doesn't slow down and I
wish it knows at that age that I would
have worked out an hour a day you know
something that I'm doing now wouldn't
have been working as hard as I am now if
you're young and you see it your weights
going somewhere when you're [ __ ] 30
so throughout your thirties and forties
and you're not the king nobody wants you
to be [ __ ] Johnnie Olympus they just
want you to do what Lee does go to the
[ __ ] 24 Hour Fitness and write the up
elliptical for 40 minutes then you go
home and everybody's at least you don't
feel that bad if you do decide to eat a
quarter pound anyone and you don't have
to do 45 was the first time I did it I
did 15 I couldn't I was I didn't think I
was gonna get to 15 and I went home and
suffer for 15 hours so why as long at
this point as long as I do 30 I'm like
this better than doing nothing
I get 400 calories in but it's just you
moving that blood jack anything's better
than that stalemate [ __ ] blood it
moves the blood it sets all fireworks in
your brain to do other things
you like what the [ __ ] am i doing
sitting here go do other things yeah I'm
not gonna tell anyone to work out
because I used to hate it when I was
bigger like I because everyone knows
they're supposed to lose weight but the
thing I would look for if you're looking
for inspiration is something you told me
about and now I can't not see it
everywhere is the bigger guys and girls
who bruises around their ankles because
their blood isn't flowing it freaks me
out like there it's eat away at the skin
they [ __ ] deserve it to me hurry up
yeah cuz you'll have it now no no I
refuse to have it I work on it work on
it you have my you rub those things you
know move around if you do get on a
plane I don't want that either and that
fat ass once you see the fat ankle
twelve down terrifies me it's just all
downhill after that man you can't get
that blood color you laying around that
[ __ ] ankle [ __ ] no it's just stale
blood is just by brown blood that comes
out yet so maybe I would hammer movies
but ya know I just know I just saw
people's heads get [ __ ] it you know a
few people who've been emailing me my
heart goes out to you guys thank you
Fidel is alive in case thank god he's
not alive and kicking he's alive for a
long [ __ ] time we've been together 16
years for those been around for 14 years
necks like May she was telling me she
tells a big cat now fat big big leopard
big like she always seemed super healthy
always seem super healthy always happy
always me Allan always wants the first
pet if you're gonna pet say in the
people if the veterinarian pulled me
aside and go he's a really good cat like
he's the once a while he goes off the
deep end
he likes to [ __ ] around with hairy and
tortured Demi and [ __ ] but beside and he
takes abuse he's the biggest kind of
having the house he thinks abuse from
the other cats and every once in a while
he just snaps one of the best fights I
ever saw was having again super bad
really two different it was like John
Jones and Cormier yeah they [ __ ]
forth they went backwards and they found
to a laundry box and they got going and
the laundry box flipped over say which
in that laundry box I know I had to pick
it up super bad for now at each other by
the neck this one on for about a month -
every time they'd see each other they
make those loud noises I go get the [ __ ]
out of here but he's alive and kicking
you know my wife said that uh you know I
got this morning gave him a special food
my play with him a little bit when I
went in the shower when I came back it
jumped the fence
to his cat with a box so you know he's
alive he's not kicking the way he was
kicking before he's not old Fidel you
know he torments you and [ __ ] but uh is
that cuz I had never experienced a pet
dying when I had a hamster that died but
that wasn't the same as my dog does it
make you not want to get more animals
cause of like I don't know if I could
anymore you always gonna get animals
somebody's always animals come to you
comes into your life if that animals
meant for you
it's the regardless of what you say
regardless of what you say as a person I
can't have cats I'm allergic to dogs I
don't know when dogs in my life I gotta
get right when you see the animal that
belongs to you
you'll know it you feel okay it could be
a [ __ ] parrot you might call me one
thing was I went to a [ __ ] thing and
bought a chinchilla you know I don't
give a [ __ ] what you buy every animal
has a purpose and you have a purpose
will alone was just finding the right
animal I've been very fortunate you know
well my mother died I had a dog you know
yeah his name was crystal I called on
crystal from crystal THC your mom I
never did I never had to I just called
him crystal and she didn't know he was
white with little brown spots and was he
the first dog I ever had not really he
was one of those dogs that came in and
out of the house we had two dogs at one
time there were guard dogs that my mom
had to give away cuz one kept running
away and biting people and giving that
Terrace when I first moved to Jersey so
my mom gave him to her buddy in the
Bronx and I would see him to dogs for
years and we had a champion who was my
dad's dog who died when I was like
Mercy's age
and then we have we had this crystal you
know and crystal was a good little dog I
didn't know what I was doing I was a
young kid I was playing football with
them weights I was just discovering
titties and fingering people and [ __ ] I
didn't have you know it's not like you
had the internet that you got a dog and
you read up on that dog and stuck in an
encyclopedia you know and I gave the dog
woof and then what happened my mom died
and I had this dog and I was moving in
with friends I couldn't bring the dog
and I had to give the dog away and that
stayed with me for a long time I always
let that dog down everything my mom died
and me moving high school there's that
no Social Security I had this [ __ ]
dog and I had to give him away that know
who to give him wait till I came away to
my mom's friends and she was on 51st
Street so I would go out at nights and
get [ __ ] up and walked by the dog
let's go buddy and she would put the dog
outside so like 2:00 in the morning and
I told you I would jump the fence and
going it's house and play with it and I
don't know what happened I lost contact
with the dog over the years and then
always stayed with me I always wanted to
I always owed the universe one I always
felt like I owed the universe one that
happens to people sometimes they get out
you know get an animal and they have to
move or their boyfriends have allergies
or their girlfriends can't have a cat in
the house there's always something you
have to give them all up I think that's
one of the toughest things you have to
do in your life I know it was for me as
a young man yeah I don't ever want to
bail on my animals like one side one
like I won't go on vacation we're having
a hard time by next holiday we want to
go to New York and spend you know six
days with the child will take it to the
tree and this and this you know you go
away she goes away you know lady I can't
expect my friends to go over there sit
there for an hour with these animals
right and I just can't leave for nine
days and I have somebody come and feed
them and leave these animals have
emotions you know they they they they
used to a certain lifestyle I spend time
with my cats I like it I enjoy it I'm
not gonna lie these people over know
when I left this morning I packed all
over
I picked up three of them and kiss them
when I when I offend them you know
that's how you supposed to treat your
[ __ ] animals
you know why have an animal why have an
animal via this people I think willing
to give love to a [ __ ] animal
so and I look at my cats and I got to
tell you something they were all meant
for me every single one of those cats in
a room God put him on this planet for me
to a doctor
I just know were you anxious adopting
strays like it not even just from the
shelter of like strays on the street
well there were little kids and I knew
what their options were I knew that they
were gonna die if somebody didn't take
them they were gonna die these animals
were good cats these animals were you
know they were tough they came from the
samurai they had a good bloodline you
know mama was back there for years
getting [ __ ] and spitting out kittens
and she never I mean she was tough as
nails she had like [ __ ] 19 livers and
the years we were back there you know
Wow but I have no regrets about none of
those cats I love them more the same I
make time for them you know when they
call home when I'm out of town I ask
about mercy and I asked about certain
cats I know but acting weird that week
before I left you know every week has
every cat every week I have a different
dilemma with the cats
now that they're sick but super Bad's
attack of Harry
Demi's attacking Lulu you know there's
always something that's weird out there
different person and that's it and every
week everybody changes every Monday goes
back to zero and now Fidel's got a beef
this week with this guy this guy keeps
jumping the [ __ ] fence but I enjoy
yes I enjoy they say when people have
animals they look they live longer and I
think that it's the secret love you have
with this animal that you owe nothing to
it it owes you nothing I mean you could
pretty much I mean I don't know what the
thing is with lions and tigers a lot but
every animal wants love they have videos
of that will the people who have spent
time with like the Lions of tigers from
like an early age like this one that's
going wrong where this guy opens a door
like I had to preserve or something and
the lion jumps into his arms and it's
just like noise Liam and it looks
terrifying but love is love yeah
love is love Grey's the last cat I ever
adopted and she wasn't a kid she was
already a grown cat you know but I hit
it off on her outside she got attacked
she couldn't go back outside the way he
was gonna get away i took her and grey
now you know when I first took gray and
I pick her up but she'd go nuts
mm-hmm but grey now looks for me to pick
her up she doesn't want me to know that
I want her to pick up that she wants me
to pick her up you know yeah
she'll torment me while I'm on the
computer my legs and her tail and
torment me and then I go to touch her
chest like to lift it yeah and she'll go
away but the next time she comes she'll
stay that extra minute and let me pick
her up and I have to rub her ears and
kiss her and then rub her back and we
rub her belly and want so I could see
the little drool come out of her nose
and just fall on her chest eyes on pat
it's it's always the same so she'll
fight me yeah but now I can't get rid of
it now you know she'll be there for 20
minutes I'll be rubbing her stomach and
her face and her little sides here and a
little mustache and I can see a little
eyes look at me thanking me you know
those animals are very appreciative yeah
do you think that's why they have a lot
of those programs and prisons where they
love those look good in my tent like
Dodger catcher I saw that yeah it gives
you a purpose I gotta be honest with you
man when I had demion hand there were
kittens I couldn't wait to be home yeah
there was a funniest [ __ ] you
ever saw in your life first of all my
wife couldn't mean we didn't think we're
gonna keep Debbie and Harry
oh really so we put him under the table
my wife made a little barrier she called
the freedom bill freedom town and it had
fences and little cat toys in there and
a blanket and they lived in there but
the girl I was supposed to take him move
to Orange County and never call this
back so for a month they were just a
Limbaugh I had him
and I remember being out at night and
getting cold and run at home just to do
coke and play with those [ __ ]
you could take a piece of paper yeah
putting the front of Damon he was a
kitten he won pooch really I'd sit then
go from the University of whatever he'd
run through the [ __ ] piece of paper I
did that for hours that's how much of a
[ __ ] I am so I loved all that [ __ ] I
know how did you figure out Demeter's
knuckle sandwich that's the best thing I
love my wife my wife plays your knuckle
saying would you the whole hit but you
hit but surface head but your head now
your face whatever you want that but you
take showers listen you give any animal
dog Joey you're cat yeah Cat could be
dog too good a dog it was just a
different situation different time yeah
so that's been what are you go sleep
[ __ ] the cats
my goals are 300 out of 365 I'd like to
be down to 115 that's my goal way I'd
like to make this podcast I don't know
if it I don't think more times a week
but I'd like to grow the audience which
would of course it obviously would make
us more money but I really like that
Colin show and I really know I like to
do and I'm like I like going to Vegas
and I see talking later I see Freddie
and his wife and I see or we go to
Austin last year in okay spooky is still
tweeting I mean and buy shirts and and
every time I send a shirt to Australia
oh my god you serious like it's just so
cool like someone like you to fight look
we basically kind of have friends in
Australia and we have that guy in China
just that's really I would like to grow
it I'd like to obviously some of its
professional but it just it was it
someone it's been though it was a really
funny er last year was it's funny
because I looked at the professional
angle of my goals but I knew it the
personal that would be a little bit more
I had to be a little bit more of my
personal goals you know I've been
writing these stupid [ __ ]
goldfuss 1989 mm-hmm and I wrote these
things every year and I looked at them I
realized when I was [ __ ] up on coke
just to see where I was it kept me on
course if you have a hard time staying
and of course today it's kind of new
[ __ ] notebook open up the page and
the first page clear it cuz that one
always gets [ __ ] up so move it over in
the second page write your goals you
know one whose weight I want to be a
better person you know I want to be a
nicer person I want to have more empathy
you know I wrote that down I'm gonna be
more effective Society I feel like times
that I'm as apathetic and I am but I
also have to attack it as a comic so I
don't want people to think that you know
I wrote different things like that but I
think that sometimes people worry but
well I want to make a million [ __ ] dog
I wanna [ __ ] you gonna make a million
[ __ ] dollars okay how the [ __ ] you
gonna make a million dollars if you're
late for your [ __ ] meeting right do
you follow me so making a million
dollars is gonna do with you it has to
do with you being early for [ __ ]
meetings right you know I you know 10
minutes early and prepared and your
shoes shine I'm gonna smile on your face
and you know know I'll fall on your
[ __ ] breath you know I've had
distinctly where I've gone to meetings
in the mornings with people and I gotta
tell you something man
I party for [ __ ] years I gotta hide
for [ __ ] years
I gotta before the means I'll tell you
what I do if I get high before the means
I put Visine in my [ __ ] eyes I
brushed my teeth and I [ __ ] gargle
and I take a little tap I hate [ __ ]
cologne I've had the same little bottle
of CK one three years you know when I
get high and I have a meeting at a
network or yeah hey I took a little dot
I put unto my neck of something that's
it
yeah just to stroll off the reef I won't
smoke in that suit I'm wearing something
I go to these [ __ ] meetings sometimes
and I get hit in the [ __ ] face with
alcohol breath constable if it's after
lunch in Hollywood you definitely know
I'm talking 10 o'clock you know I got my
sugar lolis now I never ran into that
that's bad but that bad [ __ ] cocaine
or yeah like that bad [ __ ] you know
and I'm not there the judge no but I'm
just saying Jesus [ __ ] Christ Oh at
least I thought I covered my tracks
better when I was getting high right
yeah and that's that was something that
was big for me this past year it like
even if you think you're doing a great
job you can look at there's something
that you can change always always and
it's the same thing with losing weight
for me but even even working like a lot
of 2013 I like the pop we were doing
pretty good numbers and we changed some
stuff at the beginning last year and our
number our numbers doubled months last
December - this past December and I I
think I'm doing a better job I think the
podcast has gone a lot better
you've become a like I told you the last
three sets I saw you last week
we're the best three I've seen I think
ever so it's pretty cool to be on this
podcast Lee that really pisses me off is
I love these people
mm-hmm you know when I go out and do
shows and I get to shake one hand the
person says one thing about the podcast
I got to meet you hmm and now you paid
for a ticket to come see me guess what
well no no I owe you something cuz
that's how life works out you know
that's what we do as friends do I owe
you something so you know what I owe
them to prepare this the day before I
come in here mm-hmm to try to do this
sometime to try to be consistent with it
that's what I owe you people for
listening for taking the time to come to
the shows I can't go six years ago I
didn't have you guys so I don't give a
[ __ ] what came out of my mouth or my
cell on stage no I'm nervous because I
know you guys work hard and you're
paying you're making time to come see me
you understand my mentality right even
if I always try to give you something
though it may be funny it may not be
funny about [ __ ] try it
I don't ever want you to go I want to
see me do the exact same material to the
piece and the exact same words no I'm
always trying I'm always thinking you
know you guys the [ __ ] first thing
and last thing on my mind every [ __ ]
morning I can't every day I can't lie to
you we you know it you know you know
every conversation we have is about how
can we make the show better more
consistent you know topic whatever
guests we're always trying to switch it
up I don't
Balam abaya myself ever and I want you
guys the same that had the same attitude
don't ever sleep on yourself oh we got
the call yeah
oh [ __ ] it's my main man Happy New Year
my brother
Telly's ano nuevo me amigo
you know when Lee and I were talking
last week who we wanted as a Gatsby and
I kept thinking Billy Corbin because I
had that 3030 taped to watch it but
every time I'm in the hotel room the
last couple weeks I catch the last now
we're here 20 minutes here 18 minutes
here last night I sat down with my wife
and I watched the whole thing
and Billy you're a bad [ __ ]
Billy Corbin's on the air what's
happening brother good morning good
morning to you we made it to another
year yes we did Billy Coleman
it blows me the [ __ ] away too
I always think I don't know how to say
the Florida does it like I don't know
how we managed to whether it's just like
collapsing under the weight of our own
ineptitude and corruption or just or
we're global warming finally you know
sea-level rise is coming in swallowing
up the state I just don't know how we
make it I really I really don't I there
was any kind of biblical event we would
certainly be the first to go I think you
know like we certainly deserve it we've
got it comin
whereas Clint Eastwood says in
Unforgiven we've all got it coming but I
think Florida Florida's got to go first
I'm you know that that's why that's why
I'm here I like I want I want prime real
estate for just whatever biblical fate
is gonna befall this state you know like
a front row seat because I think it's uh
I think it's gonna be it's gonna be bad
one day but we made it to another year
I'm always I'm always impressed [ __ ]
Florida is a crazy [ __ ] state
when you think about it I look at the
kids that ended up in Florida I grew up
with like the people ended up in my you
know I grew up in West New York North
Berg in that area
it's a big Cuban population and I always
see who went back home you know and
you're like I got that guy now because
it takes a certain person to live in
Miami
I love corruption I love larceny I love
drugs I love [ __ ] and that's all the
Miami and South Florida is correct I
think that's not an unfair assessment
you're looking at the essential
ingredients of the community you hit
upon most of them I like Jewish people I
like Cuban people I mean everything
about Florida pointsme but I don't think
I'm ready I never thought I was ready
for Miami every time I thought I was
ready for Miami go down and go not yet
maybe you know - these are [ __ ]
major-league savages down here
major-league savages in Miami with no
they just steal they just feed I I
always say you'll see it on my Twitter
feed all the time whenever some
whacked-out usually national news story
strikes anywhere in America almost
anywhere we always start looking for the
Florida connection because there's but
the more whacked-out the story is the
more likely that there's a Florida
connection and I'll post news stories
and I'll be like there's always a
Florida connection whether we found it
or not I mean it was just this this
police chief in Peachtree Georgia and he
was moving his gun
at 4:30 in the morning while he's in bed
and according to him it accidentally
goes off and he shoots his wife what he
what he first reported to 911 twice but
actually turned out to only accidentally
shoot her once and sure as [ __ ] where
was he a police chief report before
Peachtree Georgia took Tequesta in Palm
Beach County where he worked in two
police departments was divorced three
times and this third wife was actually
his first wife or something that came
back to him who had previously accused
him of cheating and being a
uses and of course the whole thing is
like the florida connection the entire
the entire story and that just goes back
to I mean whether it's the 9/11
terrorists living in flight training in
in Florida or or all the Ponzi schemers
I mean Bernie Madoff in Palm Beach or
you go back to 1926 for crying out loud
there was a an Italian immigrant who got
busted in Massachusetts and he fled the
jurisdiction and he goes to Florida the
Jacksonville area in Duval County and he
starts doing these like land schemes
that were popular in Florida you know
selling swampland and lies that came
true promising people you know 50% on
their money or whatever he gets busted
they're in in Jacksonville runs across
the state flees across the state to
Tampa starts running the same scam he
finally gets busted there gets convicted
does prison time they extradite him back
to Boston where he does prison time and
the guy's name was Charles Ponzi and
he's the guy for whom they and he
invented the Ponzi scheme and the last
place in America that he plied his
namesake scam before he was deported
back to Italy was in Florida because
there's just there's always a Florida
connection with every fucked-up story
what about the what about the guy the
booster in the documentary who stole
eight hundred million dollars oh sure I
did Nevin Shapiro you're talking about
the a it's the University of Miami I
like to say that guilty by geography
because you're not going to see this in
Kansas or Oklahoma but when you have
high net worth people which is of course
what universities are you are going
after for donations when you have high
net worth people in Miami invariably
you're gonna find yourself with a
certain percentage of nefaria
characters or people who got you know
whose money is you know or ill-gotten
gains and and the University of Miami
has deep connections to not one not
- but three completely separate and
different unrelated Ponzi schemers
including Alan Stanford who isn't even
bigger scam artist this guy was a form
of former scuba instructor from Texas
who opens a bank for crying out loud and
and the state of Florida he comes here
he wants the UH he wants to sell these
like completely questionable financial
instruments these these certificates of
deposit from from an offshore bank that
this guy started in the in the the
Virgin Islands which immediately no one
else will Antigua was where it was a
bank in Antigua opened by a former Texas
scuba instructor so where does he think
he's gonna have the easiest time of it
in Florida of course and the securities
of folks in the state of Florida
actually license him to sell these
completely questionable instruments he
opens a huge office in downtown Miami
starts selling these certificates of
deposit it's a gigantic multi-billion
dollar Ponzi scheme and of course
University of Miami finds themselves the
defendants in a quarterback lawsuit
because he donated millions of dollars
to the University of Miami and to their
uh their they're actually award-winning
an incredible marine biology school that
they have and now there you have the the
bankruptcy trustee who's trying to get
some money back for the victims of this
guy is suing the University of Miami
then as you mentioned you've got Nevin
Shapiro who is the high-profile booster
of the University of Miami football and
and basketball programs he got busted in
at eight hundred nine hundred million
dollar Ponzi scheme and had donated a
lot of money to the University including
having a plaque with his name and face
for a time on the student-athlete lounge
at the at the University of Miami yeah
that's what that picture you have in the
documentary of the of the president
looking at the fifty thousand dollar
check in the bowling alley oh my god
that was crazy smiling Linda Joey knows
that's Miami man as long as the checks
are clearing and the booze is flowing
nobody asks any questions about where
where the money comes from
like Miami it's not like I was okay I
try to compare it to people so they
understand it's not like the Northeast
where there's like old money you know
our legacies where Oh who's you know
what's your last name who's your family
you know it's not like that in Miami
anybody who's rich down here is for the
most part nouveau riche
you know everybody's new rich so it's
like nobody cares about where you come
from you're here and you've got money
it's like everybody's like you know the
great [ __ ] gatsby down here you know
it's just like as long as long as the
party's going on
Gnomeo raging nobody cares and and
that's happened time and again there's a
great story about that that we're doing
a doc on this is back in this a 90 story
Chris Paciello and the liquid nightclub
it was called liquid and it was the
first of that South Beach Renaissance it
was the first like front page kind of
nightclub in South Beach back when you
know South Beach was just making that
transition from God's waiting room you
know inhabited mostly by by elderly
Jewish Holocaust survivors and then of
course the marielito criminals who had
kind of filtered their way through
either dead or or in prison or up to
Jersey or Chicago and this guy opens
this nightclub takes over a space from
Mickey Rourke and his sister which was I
mean in case it's not abundantly clear
was was mob-connected
and this this particular location his
nightclub burns down what they call an
Italian fire sale or get struck by
Jewish lightning as a result of a
cigarette wedged in a couch yes that's
right in a couch that's right that's
right a couch house and joy knows how
this works and he opens up this new
place liquid and Liza Minnelli shows up
to the red carpet and says wow this is
like studio 54 the next thing you know
this guy good-looking young Italian kid
in his 20s who allegedly came down here
with a buddy who used to sell ecstasy at
liquid in New York with a quote
motorcycle accident settlement check any
and opens this nightclub and
comes I mean like like a tabloid darling
he's sleeping with Madonna and Sofia
Vergara Niki Taylor and and it's this
whole thing and what winds up happening
is he turns out to be a gangster you
know from from Staten Island who was
running various Bank bank heists and was
involved in the in a fail home invasion
that wound up one murder of a Staten
Island housewife and it's just one of
those ones that this guy was throwing
fundraisers for the mayor of Miami Beach
and the Miami Children's Hospital uh you
know at one point and months later he's
he's a mugshot with a completely
different last name it's not Chris
Paciello it's Chris Ludvigsen and the
the New York you know the diligence got
him on the cover of the newspaper do you
think of these people kept a lower
profile they wouldn't get caught there's
no low profile in Miami oh you go big
you go big I mean you have to [ __ ] go
big well I have this question I gotta
ask you something because I tell people
every day you have the best way to feed
there is I [ __ ] I laugh twenty times a
[ __ ] day with you what is it with
black women
in Miami they lose their [ __ ] mind
they stop combing their hair then they
throw their kids in the oven what the
[ __ ] what is it with black momentum I am
at they [ __ ] kill their kids and [ __ ]
that son does do they look like James
Brown a mug shot their heads all [ __ ]
up and [ __ ] it is something about black
women in Miami lose their [ __ ] mind
and kill their kids you have like three
stories last week about black women
[ __ ] lighting the kid on fire she
shot her husband the one what was the
stuff where did this happen let the lady
took the the baby took the handgun out
of the person shot the woman at the
supermarket
thank God that wasn't Florida but her
cousin is related to something in Miami
I'm still I'm still waiting I'm still
waiting on the Florida connection on
that one but
that was in Idaho of all places um which
sounds completely sketchy I mean a
two-year-old in the mother's purse
you know the mothers walking around
Walmart of course with a concealed
weapon a permit in a legal concealed
weapon but the kid somehow pulls the
trigger
and shoots and kills the mom which is
just horrible um but like how does that
happen
like what kind of what kind of week
trigger is this on there on this gun I
mean I've never heard I mean a
two-year-old having the strength to I
mean it's I don't know if there's more
to it certainly you're waiting you know
waiting waiting on the Florida
connection but those were white people
in Idaho and I will tell you that um
everybody goes crazy
not just black woman in Florida and it's
funny you talk about the the hair I
always think about that when I when you
see these people on meth I think one of
the first like symptoms of meth is
really irresponsible hair style
decision-making I mean you see it like
their hair goes straight to hell you're
like what color is that supposed to be
and what's with your roots like right
away here like what's going on here you
need to go and get your your hair done
again there was these two people this is
like one of my New Year's stories this
this white dude and this white lady were
found what they had locked themselves in
like a supplies closet at a college in
Daytona Beach and they had been in there
for like three days and the police say
that they had found some drug
paraphernalia related to crack smoking
in the scouring blankets yeah well yeah
it was one of the others cracker meth
I mean you could sort of like tell right
away and it was just like and and they
had like locked themselves in and with a
guy like colds for help even though they
had locked themselves in they could get
out whenever they wanted to but the guy
like cold for hell the door wasn't even
locked the door doesn't lock from the
inside they said the police were like
how did they lock themselves in and they
just
they were freaked out yeah yeah they
were Chilean just started freaking out
in the closet at the Daytona Beach yeah
I don't know when was until you been to
Daytona Beach like in recent years at
all or ever known it's a crazy place 95
years probably oh well you're not
missing anything still famous for being
a place where you can drive your car on
the beach you know physically drive your
car on the beach and the only thing this
town had going for them was MTV Spring
Break you know would come down every
year every year yeah and do the live
broadcast that was like that put them on
blast that put them on spotlight well
the city you know the the city leaders
and their infinite wisdom decided that's
not the reputation that they want to
have anymore and so they throw out they
literally chase MTV away and then they
have nothing the recession hits you know
in 2008 and the police becomes like
tumbleweed like a ghost town I went
there I had a girlfriend an
ex-girlfriend all the time she was from
there and so we were driving across the
state we had never been and it was one
of the most depressing experiences of my
life I mean it was a beach town where
nobody wanted to go to the beach I mean
I don't even know how to describe remind
me it reminded me of Brigantine New
Jersey in the winter you know who like a
beach town there's a beach town in the
in the offseason where like businesses
were just shuttered up and like people
were just financially depressed and I'm
addicted to drugs and it was really one
of the saddest things I've ever seen and
some of the worst stories out of Florida
come out of come out of Daytona Beach
it's really it's really just terrible I
really really really enjoy you know I
gotta be honest with you I grew up on
football I grew up on basketball and
once 85 came Billy I just stopped
watching you know I just just drugs and
being a criminal and trying to get your
life together and getting locked up and
somewhere along the line I missed
everything
you know and there were flashes I
remember Michael Irvin at Miami and I
remember a couple games but I didn't get
to know the players and the names and
all that stuff and stats and the
National Championship to me you know
whatever I don't [ __ ] know it's
January 8 some years is January 3rd I
can't make up your [ __ ] mind you know
you know I watched the first one you did
that you you know and I was blown away
with Luke and everything this one blew
me away a little more because I didn't
know they had gone down that far I
didn't know that what point I mean it's
amazing how they turned the program back
around by 2001 that little black dude
Santana Moss he's got a fan how
emotional he got and how and the blades
now blades look look to the guy next
year and say he's the baddest
[ __ ] in here like I thought he
was saying that he was going crazy he
was going crazy now what were the blades
brothers which one shot himself well got
shot at a party
well there were there was three blades
brothers um ow
died in a car accident there was like a
string of of car accidents like it was
terrible it took really popular big-time
Miami football players and good former
football players including Jerome Brown
who was like he was like the AL blades
of the of the 80s he died in a car
accident and but but the two brothers
bene and Brian who were we'll call him
the original you know the original
blades brothers because they both they
both played they played in the 1980s and
they they're still around
thankfully they both went on to play
professionally
you had Sean Taylor of course who would
would tragically went along he's playing
for the Redskins would go would be shot
and killed in his home you had Marlin
Barnes which is a really sad story from
96 it was the the spring before I
started at the University of Miami in
the fall he was beaten to death in his
on-campus apartment
at the University of Miami it was a it
was his girlfriend's ex-boyfriend who
targeted them and beat them both to
death in the on-campus apartment he was
found by his by his roommates in all
football players of course in the in the
apartment and actually Ray Lewis was one
of Marlin Barnes roommates or apartment
Nate Miami - oh yeah absolutely right
Louis Edie read lines one snap these are
the guys that that played in you know a
Ray Lewis and Warren Sapp played in that
in that kind of grim era you know I'd
like to early into the mid 90s so they
they kind of fall in a moment in history
that almost is like between the two
documentaries you know like the first
doc kind of ends in in about ninety two
and then we're kind of in 95 96 you know
a little bit when the when the second
documentary starts so like yeah so they
were in that but they started the trends
I mean the University of Miami has you
know for I mean 17 years 18 years on end
had at least one first-round draft pick
um every single year consecutively it's
this it's the sync it's the the greatest
run to this day in the history of the
NFL Draft they were set pretty sure it
was 17
well 17 first-round draft picks just out
of that one class that 2001 class is
what what is it
Levitt our calls it a nuclear absurdity
because the talent on that one roster is
just psychotic because you have 38 guys
from one college football team that went
pro which is insane 17 of them
first-round draft picks well one of them
one of the great stats that we didn't
put in the movie the hurricane that
there was a hundred and forty nine
consecutive
regular season weeks in the NFL where a
former Miami Hurricanes scored a
touchdown in an NFL game so for years
and years and years on end there was
there was never a week of NFL football
regular season where you didn't have a
Miami hurricane scoring a touchdown
which is like insane but that was the
level of talent that started coming out
of that school in the 80s but it was
really the nineties where it where it
hit that stride and you mentioned
Santana Moss I mean you know I'm a
little guy Santana isn't much bigger
than I am and he just started I think
his 14th season in the NFL the average
career in the NFL is three point three
years so like you had these guys they
were just a special kind of of in shape
you know a special kind of condition
they were trained you know on another
level and and and you had you know
first-round draft picks backing each
other up you know future Pro Bowlers uh
who were sitting on on the bench in the
chicken in the late 90s early 2000s
because the depth of talent the
competition on the team was just
absolutely out of out of control
well I wouldn't I went to Fort
Lauderdale last June and when I walked
outside of the airport I was already
sweating I couldn't imagine doing it
football practices in that heat in the
summer it's a great point I think that's
part of what that's part of the
conditioning I mean you practice you
know at high noon in Miami and and
you're just you're just gonna eventually
be a better physical specimen and that's
exactly what happened I mean these guys
weren't training it if you didn't drop
out obviously along the way with which a
lot of people did you were just going to
turn into a better you know more
resilience and powerful football player
and that's exactly what these guys did I
think someone did the math and deal with
the Contra
acts of a lot of these guys that the
2001 Miami Hurricanes I think word about
they would have cost about 198 million
dollars in the NFL or did or didn't cost
198 million dollars in the NFL with all
the starters and draft picks that went
on went on to place you had you know
people say to this day that that team
the 2001 Miami Hurricanes in 2001 would
have gone to the playoffs in the NFL
with that with that level of even
college talent it's it's it's remarkable
one thing I noticed about that
documentary you know I went to the
University of Colorado I had a friend
that I went down ASU and I used to go to
that campus a lot when I was a kid I go
to Rutgers to play basketball and I saw
the teams there that was assembled when
I got when I was younger to go to five
star basketball camp in the eighth grade
I got a scholarship and I got to see
Dominique Wilkins and all these kids you
know and one thing I learned last night
after watching that documentary and
watching the first one takes a certain
player to go to Miami you have to know
it you sophomore year in high school
first off they're on there walking a
thin line they all walk this in line you
and I both know it that they were all on
that thuggery line okay they all had a
little RC in their blood and they all
could beat the [ __ ] out of it you know
they could they could have taken their
lives two ways and I see all these big
black guys smiling and laughing in the
interviews and I loved it but tonight
once in a while you throw a white dude
in there and that white dude was crazier
than the black dudes he Jeremy Shockey
yeah oh my god I know him personally he
hangs out with loops oh really
yeah I met him when he was a giant new
jersey with loops at the [ __ ] ground
round they're doing this thing that dude
is [ __ ] nuts you know you had another
white dude that was blond head to her
beautiful smart Greg Olson that dude was
for you to hang with those brothers he
did a rap song
you gotta be [ __ ] nuts because those
brothers lift you up those black dudes
and when you're white you hang out with
that many black dudes it lifts you up it
makes you a different type of [ __ ]
Savage I'm thinking to myself if I had
been blessed with the football gifts and
I hadn't got a scholarship there's only
one school I couldn't go to Miami that
was it that's it I would I wouldn't mind
getting the helmet and beating the [ __ ]
out of you with that helmet I wouldn't
have mind doing a grandma blow and I
wouldn't have mind taking fifty thousand
from responses and getting my dick
sucked in my balls licked it takes a
certain kind of [ __ ] student you know
I was in Colorado and I seen all those
bad teams but way before your time Billy
the University of Colorado had this
horrible reputation because it's a white
city and you have these black kids and
then and they you know according to
neighbors Magee and all these [ __ ]
not did these kids but they always
accused the the the quarterback whatever
his name was a selling crack that on the
weekends he was a [ __ ] he covered in LA
and get get crackling drive back to
Colorado on the weekend and sell it but
these guys all came from [ __ ] especially
the ones and and and your documentary
those black kids in Miami didn't come
from no [ __ ] great homes you could
tell that was a popular saying in the
80s during recruiting was was regardless
of what color nationality where they say
like is this a Miami guy he's gonna be a
Miami guy you gotta know it yet on this
Penn State guys there's guys that want
to go to army there's guys that want to
go to Notre Dame there's guys that want
to go to Nebraska to go to Miami you
gotta have a certain [ __ ] animalistic
savagery to you it just say you could
tell all of them had that little thing
that they could have gone either way
could have gone either way and you could
you're saying I mean have there was one
case where the kid got shot
who gets [ __ ] shot in college who
hangs out with these [ __ ] people I
didn't hang out with people in college
that carry guns and I'm [ __ ] nuts they
did down it's Miami yeah they said that
like he the guy who his roommate who
think I got shot said he had his gun
yeah they all said like the new coach
made them turn in their guns and they
were can you [ __ ] believe that oh it
was funny so uh dan Levitt art is
sitting next to Butch Davis at the
premiere of the you part 2 this was just
two days before the movie premiered on
on ESPN last month and uh they get to
that part in the documentary where Butch
Davis asks the students to student
athletes to please turn in their guns
and Butch Davis leans it over to Dan
Levitt are during the movie and says I
only got half of them because it's not
everybody turned not everybody turned
their gun in some some students and
perhaps rightfully so considering some
of the incidents off field some of them
felt like they needed to protect
themselves and listen it's Florida
something you know people today still
need to uh to protect themselves I think
I would I would advise anybody here to
uh to uh consider you know concealed
carry permit and maybe not keep it in
their purse in the shopping cart with
their children at Walmart but to
consider you know concealed carry permit
if you're gonna live in Florida after
the premiere anybody come up to you and
say they didn't like what you put in the
movie or they were disappointed have you
had any of those I mean not from I loved
the film for the film Billy I'm just
talking about one of the guys that were
there any players and the coaches that
came up to you and said you know Billy
the [ __ ] yeah there's there's always a
few of those because when you you know
I'm not shy about my my my affinity for
Miami is a location as a football
program I'm obviously a fan but at the
same time we try to be objective I mean
we kind of show it works at all I mean
and it's it's not all a a love story and
a glory story I mean a lot of it is a
little dark and and and scandalous and
so there were certainly people who were
disappointed about the the focus the
second half on Nevin Shapiro the Ponzi
schemer the scandals the downfall let's
say you know the first hour is the first
half because it's about 100 minutes of
it the first half is this kind of
football centric celebratory nostalgic
trip with with not only the greatest
college football team of all time but
arguably one of the greatest NFL teams
ever assembled with that talent and then
the second half I think is what it opens
up a little bit more because for me I
think these sports documentaries or
sports movies are most successful the
less they're about sports you know and
the more they're about something else
they're trying to to kind of give you
the bigger picture of whether it was you
know how Miami transitioned into the
early zeroes you know into the kind of
white-collar you know crime capital of
America where we perfected all of these
different schemes everything of course
real estate schemes and Medicare fraud
which was a
remains a major economic engine in the
state of Florida at the governor
reelected last November of the state of
Florida was the CEO of the of the
hospital company responsible for the
largest Medicare fraud in the history of
America they paid over 1 billion dollars
in penalties the man made his fortune on
Medicare fraud he's the governor of the
state of Florida um you think well who
better I guess to be the governor of the
state of Florida than then someone who
knows a little something about one of
our biggest our state's biggest
industries and of course Ponzi schemes
and that you know Miami became a you
know was it was less the cocaine Cowboys
and more about the white-collar crime
and so we talked about that a little bit
and you know so there's certainly people
who who were in it for the football
nostalgia who are like did you really
have to go you know that far that deep
into it and I don't know I think the
answer is yes yes none of what you were
you were getting into about being a
Miami guy and why it's it's unique to be
here and that that darkness that edge is
part of the
part of the appeal um you know and and
listen this is a guy who Nevin Shapiro
who fooled people a lot richer and a lot
smarter than a bunch of teenage football
players you know he was swindling
doctors and lawyers and really
intelligent people
he was swindling Donna shillelagh the
president of the University of Miami who
was on the Bill Clinton's cabinet you
know Health and Human Services Secretary
so he was fooling alone so yeah I
thought that that this was an
interesting interesting kind of guy an
interesting character also not alumni at
the University of Miami but but to me
he's just one in a long line of schemers
and scammers and swindler some of whom
you know we have their names on on
streets here and now here in Miami I
mean for crying I was trying to put it
into perspective you know Nevin Shapiro
was involved in a 900 million dollar
Ponzi scheme but Marlins Park will cost
taxpayers 2.4 billion dollars so who's
the bigger who is the bigger you know
hustler is it in is it Nevin Shapiro or
is it Jeff Lori on the ownership of the
Miami Marlins major league baseball team
like but but but but one of them goes to
federal prison and the other one is a
you know is a local pillar of the
community I mean but that's the problem
that's the gray area of of Miami of
Florida and I think progressively of
America it's like it's now all like it
everybody's anybody with any modicum of
success is a hustler to some extent and
it just becomes you know about whether
or not you can walk that fine line and
be friends and pay off the right people
to avoid any consequences for it yeah
Miami pioneers that lack of
accountability well it's not Miami it's
everywhere
if you throw money at somebody you know
right now in the UFC in two weeks this
Conor McGregor kid is fighting everybody
knows he's gonna beat up gonna Seaver
and then
put him in a [ __ ] arena with Jose
Aldo everybody knows the fighters no
it's it's well-known that it's a scam
give them [ __ ] Frankie Edgar let's see
what a [ __ ] this goes but no they know
but they just want that payoff in
Ireland they know that if they sell in
the ring out they walk out of there with
30 million dollars they don't give a
[ __ ] what they over see anything for
money you know and a lot of people do
that I mean I'm sitting here well I'm
sitting there last night I'm saying that
a month ago when the documentary came
out and I'm like there's Nevin Shapiro
listen let's pretend I went to the
University of Colorado which I did and I
went there and I took three you know I
didn't graduate but I gotta tell you
something what happens tomorrow I get a
10 million dollar deal and I go back to
the university collar on my way I wanna
donate a hundred thousand to the [ __ ]
library but I want my honorary degree
boom I get it that's okay you know I
went for three and a half years all
right made me take two more [ __ ]
classes make me do a thesis on something
and give me the degree okay that's one
thing but for me Joe Diaz to get money
tomorrow and just to walk into Miami as
a fan and go I want to be in the [ __ ]
field with these guys that was the only
thing that depressed me that oh yeah the
field to me is [ __ ] listen you're
gonna come to my house and eat you're
gonna might you might come to the
podcast dude you'll hang out on me
you're never gonna get on stage with me
do you understand me I worked hard to
get on that stage I worked really hard I
sacrifice things that's the only thing I
didn't like about Nevin Shapiro I get in
them in Shapiro and I get the people
around them when the present that little
[ __ ] is looking at that smile on the
face you don't give a [ __ ] what Nevin
does for a living or whatever we know we
we never do look at the Mafia for 20
years what destroyed the Mafia do me a
favor Billy don't sell [ __ ] heroin
Billy we got this construction we got
prostitution we got numbers the [ __ ]
drugs the heroin people get pissed at it
got to believe that the people that were
telling you not to sell heroin were the
biggest heroin dealers Castellano was
telling John Gotti not to sell heroin
but he was taking heroin money from his
captain's that worth
greed it's great and that's what this
country was built on greed
you know greed is gonna be there to the
end the [ __ ] time for some people for
some people it they know I know that
money wouldn't make my life any much
better than what it is now I know this
now because I'm 50 I didn't know this
when I was 21 I thought if I had 10
million [ __ ] dollars that all my
problems out boy are we [ __ ] wrong
look at Bill Cosby how much money does
he have how much money is Bill Cosby
half can you imagine to die with this I
don't care how much money he has I'm not
having a drink with him no no that's
kind of new use of them and you're not
partying with him
the point is guess what in Florida they
they [ __ ] they didn't cancel him the
game was standing ovations you know
there's honor among [ __ ] thieves well
you know I what's that line I always go
to it's that Los Angeles is where you go
when you want to be somebody New York is
where you go when you are somebody in
Miami's where you go and you want to be
somebody else I mean it's the it's the
classic Christmas oh man Chris lovely
into the second second chances yeah and
the people embrace you because they're
doing the same [ __ ] thing as you are
for quite a lot of Charlie Crist just
ran for governor again
this guy was a former Republican
governor turned independent Senate
candidate turned Democratic
gubernatorial candidate I mean if that's
not an indication of a state where you
can reinvent yourself time and time
again I mean I wasn't about naming
naming streets after people in downtown
Miami there's a street which nobody
would look at nobody would look at twice
called abel Holt's Road a Boulevard
actually able Holtz Boulevard and the
the able host back in the rising of what
year he was convicted I think it was
like the the late 80s early 90s he was
famous for having paid off a mayor of
Miami Beach named Alex Dowd who later
went to federal prison and this guy lied
to a grand jury big time
big time banker down here in Miami still
a very popular and prominent member of
the community
he confessed pled guilty to lying to a
grand jury under oath in this in this
corruption investigation
and I it the street has been named after
him in downtown the joke is that Abel
Holt's Boulevard leads to the federal
courthouse okay if it actually does the
street with his name on it
takes you right to the federal
courthouse where he pled guilty to lying
to a grand jury I mean it's just like
but that that's Miami that's you know
that's that's just how we roll a little
birdie told me that you'll be here next
month it's true yeah but well know at
the end of this month it's January
already we made it oh [ __ ]
please do make no will you please give
me a call when I'm in town Louie and I
can take you out to dinner I would love
it in fact via one of my my new year's
resolutions is to start waking up as
early as you guys do know this is just
the first to get everybody started for
the year so everybody know it's a new
year and you got a [ __ ] attack this
year with different goals and different
perspective you know we just wanted to
start today at 6:00 a.m. we've been
doing them at nine eight o'clock at
night lately we do the night ones so
when you come in we'll go to dinner and
then we'll smoke a number will blow
shotgun in your face and you have you
are nope I don't know everybody's so
disappointed but I don't know we don't
want in this moment wanted to be just
the way you are when you come out of Lee
and I want how are you coming out to
town floor I don't know probably just a
few days I'm hoping to make it a little
bit longer though cuz well we come out
there very rarely and it's always so
such a short trip so I'm hoping to make
it a little longer be the last week in a
month okay please Billy let me buy you a
steak and the girlfriend let me give her
some edibles and I don't know what
happened to Florida with them not
passing that [ __ ] law because
everybody wants to smoke pot so they
jammed the [ __ ] computer boxes again
Jeb Bush was hard at work how didn't
they pass that medical
down there it's past nowhere I mean
where I got we got almost 59 that is
five nine fifty-nine percent of the vote
which is just just a remarkable thing
I mean I'll put you this way I don't
there's not a lot of politicians
including the governor of the state were
elected with 59% of the vote we have a
law here in Florida that if you want to
amend the state constitution you have to
get a supermajority so we had to cross
that 60% line
Rick Rick Scott got 48% of the vote and
one amendment - got nearly 59% of the
vote and failed but that's Florida
that's Florida math baby I mean that's
that's the way it goes I mean and and
and now you're not going to really see
unfortunately I I don't think a move on
the part of our legislators to do
anything we know it's the will of the
people we know the vast majority of the
money that went to support I mean 80
plus percent of the money that went into
a campaign against medical marijuana in
Florida was from outside the state of
Florida so the people really supporting
it were all in the state of Florida but
we were outspent and outgunned so to
speak and we still nearly passed the
damn thing I think they can see the
writing is on the wall this is you know
that's a thing in Florida you know the
further north you go the further south
you are I mean you've got now clerks of
courts tip tonight at midnight is when
the the gay marriage same-sex marriage
in Florida is basically legal as of
midnight and you've got clerks of court
these are public servants in the
northern part of the state of Florida
who are now no longer they have
cancelled all marriages like you know
yet people go to the clerk and they say
okay we'll get our license and
we can do have a ceremony right there
they're canceling all marriage
ceremonies so that they don't have to
conduct same-sex marriages so basically
telling everybody you can't we're not
doing the ceremonies here anymore
you know they'll you know get married on
the courthouse steps kind of nonsense
they won't do that anymore because they
don't want to marry same-sex couples so
that's the attitude of so it's really
two florida's that's the problem I would
you know Florida is a is a is a red
state it's a it's it's it's America's
red penis with the blue foreskin that
they wish they could just circumcise you
know off the state and truth be told we
wish it to because a lot of their
revenue in the state of hills in
Tallahassee in the state capital comes
from South Florida comes your tourists
don't go to Tallahassee tourists come to
Orlando and Miami and Palm Beach and and
the keys you know they come to South
Florida which is if guy I compare what I
say it's like Atlanta is to Georgia you
know what I mean it's just kind of like
a reasonable modern you know metropolis
in the midst of basically deliverance
you know Dueling Banjos is the rest of
the state of Florida and they just think
the scourge of marijuana was going to
you know was going to turn our white
women to jazz and black men like
literally reefer madness [ __ ]
and III but I think that that when you
see the numbers even being outspent the
way that we were you see nearly 59
percent of the vote and you know the old
guard I think is dying off and that's
the thing you have a lot of older people
who vote and then don't stick around
long enough to confront the consequences
of their electoral behavior I think that
that's I think that that's gonna change
and if we have another another shot at
this I think it's a foregone conclusion
that sick children will finally get the
medicine that they that they need that's
what it's come to in the in the state of
Florida that people were willing to look
you know eight-year-old girls who have
hundreds of seizures a day in the face
and say no you can't have them at
that your doctor says that you need this
is my business for some reason what your
private medical situation is and I'm
telling you no you have to continue
taking these toxic pharmaceutical drugs
that drug dealers and lab coats give you
that who the side effects of which are
sometimes worse than your original
symptoms and that's what you're gonna I
mean they're literally torturing
children down here and that's and that's
okay by Floridians but I don't think
that's going to be the case for for much
longer like I said I think the old guard
is dying out and there's a new
generation of Millennials and and and
and free-thinking freedom-loving
Americans
down here in Florida who are gonna
change things in this in you know in the
next in the next generation if not I'm
gonna show up with a big bag of reef and
a big dick and sling it down there I
Love You Billy Corbin [ __ ]
I hope so
we're dead gives out because if we fail
next time we're gonna need all the help
we can get I mean that's it it's gonna
be Sodom and Gomorrah time down here
because it's just this town is that you
know that that's the thing is you get a
new generation of leadership and you
think like I very optimistically just
declare that that there's going to be
some kind of a kind of a change here and
I think the only change might be the sea
level you know to drown us all which
which which at some point might just be
okay you know the only higher ground we
have or the higher elevation we have are
these condos that we built and and
continue to build just unfettered
construction and that's like that's the
name of the game down here now is
basically money laundering from South
America Eastern Europe Russia money
laundering through these these condos
and developments here in downtown Miami
especially in Brickell and South Beach
and those guys I mean that the big-time
developers here they're basically like
the cocaine Cowboys now not only with
the money laundering but they literally
just
have all of the politicians bought and
there they're free to do just about
anything that they want to do including
Rob the public coffers and get public
money for sometimes multi-billion dollar
development projects to to pay for
infrastructure improvements and these
guys are making campaign contributions
to politicians who are running unopposed
they're running unopposed they've got no
opponent they got no campaign to run but
they're getting hundreds of thousands of
dollars in legal so-called legal
campaign contributions and and again I
know that's happening everywhere but you
look in South Florida and we pioneer
that those these techniques I mean you
know they used to say the Florida of
today is the America of tomorrow and if
you want to know what calamities what
schemes and scams are going to befall
America in the next decade or two you
stick the thermometer in Florida and you
take a look at what's going on down here
and you will know you know the [ __ ]
that's going to go down nationwide and
the next decade or two and that that
there's itself out in everything you go
back to history and you realize that
Florida is the barometer it's the canary
in the coal mine for all of America's a
your biggest biggest [ __ ] storms they
all they all form or gather steam and
strength a down here in Florida it's
time to [ __ ] do something Billy call
me when you get to town I love you
[ __ ] I'm happy you called in today
it's always a knowledge of [ __ ] a
wealth of knowledge and you call in
anytime guys happy new year I love you
Billy thank you for calling man that was
[ __ ] an end there you too I loved it
with all my heart thank you I hope some
day we'll have a reason to do a part
three we'll see how it goes it's not
going well though yeah I love you
have a good week Happy New Year what's
the story there at least I am want this
story buddy a little bit of music I
gotta go take a [ __ ] pee this
my dick is backed up that's it if you're
in LA
Joey's at the improv this weekend on
Melrose major
the 10th 8:00 and 10:30 is coming
Buffalo on the 22nd to the 24th and
helium and the funny bone and Columbus
Ohio
29th to the 31st highest fun guys so far
we're back [ __ ]
sorry about that the coffee the [ __ ]
protein shake and these two things a
water had my [ __ ] blood on fire my
protein shake sucked this morning - what
are you doing because I don't drink the
same protein shake I mix them up a
little bit ah but I'm back to [ __ ] on
it that chocolate that I bought from the
other place sucked so I had to put the
on at this because the on it tastes
[ __ ] delicious oh cool I put the on
it back into that shake suck this more I
drank I'm like what the [ __ ] going on
with this because I always switching my
protein 5 that one on and there's one
other one I like to switch around it's
just sticking with two Hana Coco now
yeah now that that was interesting
Florida has always been a [ __ ] every
time I go to [ __ ] Florida you know my
mom didn't like Florida and my mom was
Cuba's could be she just thought that
something was always [ __ ] wrong down
there so if you get a if you get chances
follow [ __ ] Billy on Twitter if you
want to see it was great and I had to
try to getting it because I recorded it
like 2 or 3 times and like women's
volleyball was on and one time a game
went lame so I didn't get it and it was
just it took me a while to find it but I
watched it all last night and it's good
it's a it's a it's a longer one than I
was I was gonna be like an hour it's
like an hour 45 it's great you know it's
funny huh I stayed home from December
6th on I went to the UFC we did the
South Pointe casino which I didn't show
up this week we just got out there too
late we got aa 1:15 1:30 and they were
hungry and the mushrooms were kicking I
just didn't want to go to South Point
and [ __ ] them up you know it's a
20-minute ride out there but I tell them
we got out there would have been [ __ ]
up so I took those three weeks off and I
didn't take them off I didn't take them
off from comedy or from the podcast I
took them off from Tori from getting on
a plane I just wanted to try something
and I and I I changed my writing around
my writing day the time of day I wrote I
also started writing the book again
and I've got three chapters and I didn't
write the usual stories I wrote more
about my state of mind and what the
things were bothering me when I was
young I got three good chapters in the
exercise I just wanted it was like I was
preparing for 2015 and I'm very happy a
lot of people don't have that
opportunity I don't even think about
that like I really wanted it 2015 I
appreciate what you said about my sets
last week because you know I haven't
been performing a lot like I brought in
stage every night I I had to go out of
my comfort zone also Leigh the highway
by the way I want to cheer D'Agostino I
want to give him congratulate him he
quit the haha cafe that's awesome you
know I was on D'Agostino for about three
months I didn't want to talk about on
the podcast because I loved the Agostino
yeah he's a funny guy but Eddie Griffin
once told me something that you get him
to stand up not to have a job and that's
he was even talking about television you
know that you get him to stand up he
goes oh he got to stand up so you
wouldn't have to be somewhere at 8
o'clock in the morning and I'm not
talking about jobs a bad job something
but I'm just you know when you're a
comedian what your goal is is to finally
break away from this day job and
sometimes we fall into a comfort zone
that we think we can't make it without
that day job without that constant
income and Lee went through it last year
yeah it's a scary part when you choose
your art over your you know you said
some interesting that you wanted it to
be a more pop better podcast maybe we'd
make more money from the sponsors
I wish the sponsors run away sometimes
Lee yeah because it it puts a different
thing on the show I I want this podcast
you want this podcast to be the
strongest it could be for us to always
you know be sharp and be on top of it
and and I really enjoyed how this
podcast opened up today were you getting
are you
birds are when you told me had gone to
yoga the other day I was on the phone in
my head blew up kinda but I knew it was
a big step for you and I know it's like
when I went to Redondo Beach for the
vegan Machado's seminar on a Sunday at
12 o'clock yeah yeah yeah I [ __ ] hate
it but it opened up doors for me it
always will open up a door for you even
if you had a I mean these when you do
something out of your comfort zone even
if the experience is bad you feel hot
you get high from it because you did
something in the positive direction even
though if you didn't think the
experience was good you're still gonna
get something from Italy somewhere along
the line you're gonna get something from
it and that's what I don't think when I
see people sometimes I think they shut
themselves down you know it it it gets
very easy to be comfortable in something
and I don't want people again people
were being raised I had the same problem
and that's that I was raised like that
maybe television maybe something [ __ ]
at me that money would make your life
that much better
it really doesn't you know when you look
at your career as a stand-up where's
your musician you're not gonna make
money till you fine-tune your act it's a
catch-22 nobody's gonna pay you to
fine-tune your act right and then
nobody's gonna pay you to start music
I'm gonna start playing the ukulele
today I want to put a [ __ ] band
together nobody's that's something that
you want to do from your insides
something that comes from your inside
something that you know when you have a
job it's not a job if you enjoy it yeah
thank you check at the end of the week
oh my god how lucky am i I get to do
what I love and I get to find the check
but now you're gonna go Joey how do I
find what I love by going out of your
comfort zone that's what you're gonna
find what you love that's it yeah that's
playing the [ __ ] simple you know I
think I try as many things as I can I'm
gonna do Jitsu today oh cool I'm going
with salami today cuz I can't go over
the hill cuz the baby is sick still we
don't know what the [ __ ] going on the
baby citizen come back till Wednesday
you know for the last couple weeks I've
been knocked down on jujitsu but I
really wasn't getting anywhere with it
you know I really wasn't getting
anywhere with it I felt that I kept
going and
breathing is still bad and I still got
anxiety when I'm the bottom and I still
got to stop and stuff like I took the
flight there with Big John McCarthy we
both want a Burbank to Vegas and Big
John has a school in Valencia you know
the ultimate fighting or whatever the
[ __ ] of his obtain Vil and she does a
great job I know people from V Mac have
gone up there for the open mat and also
for his competitions he puts together
and I asked him I go what are these
problems I'm having he was first loss
Joey you're 51 years old you you're
going up against 20 year olds E and
yourself on that that's not the way you
should judge yourself you should judge
this up a little accomplishments that
you're making if you last three and a
half minutes this Monday you did better
now - Wednesday go for four minutes and
eventually he does I don't want you
straining I want you to just flow and
don't worry about what happens you know
he drew this completely different
picture on this one hour flight to Vegas
and I got excited you know I got very
excited in the Vertigo
[ __ ] me up on being on my back but it
really doesn't matter I'm going back
today and this is what you need to do as
a human being to get forward sometimes
it's not the big things it's the [ __ ]
little things Lea it really is for me
it's always been the little steps those
little baby steps blow the [ __ ] up you
know I hate going out at night Li you
know I'm to the point where for a long
time I didn't have the store so going to
flappers over how I wasn't as enjoyable
to me mm-hmm
now I go to the store and I enjoy myself
you've been down there with movies it's
a fast hit
we go in we do the set we get the [ __ ]
out of the only one time we've hung out
we got wings last week we introduced to
the Irish Oh old friend Irish iris is
the real [ __ ] deal Doug okay he got
me he gave me an edible a strong and it
was it like 30 milligrams which one the
cookie
yeah the cookie was a hundred millions
like three quarters oh yeah sorry I'd
like 25 30 milligrams I was high out of
my mind I almost lost my check outside
your car away the Long Beach Laugh
Factory first and
the Hollywood improv but no I went to
the comedies went to the comedy store
and there's this woman yelling at you
during your set and and one of the door
guys
comes over and makes it be quiet but
then as you're walking down you give her
a hug and she was probably the drunkest
I've ever seen anybody be drunk she
couldn't stand up straight and she would
get in my face and I everyone's on this
thing has seen me or heard me I I don't
I don't respond both like if you don't
like me
he's a ganger kind of leaf just if I'm
on and just and and you were torturing
me because you kept calling her back she
would leave and go dance somewhere be
like iris Ryan and you come back and get
in my face again and I just kept looking
at you like stop and you're like what
she won't leave but then you go Irish
get back your Irish she thought I had
coke she kept thinking let me talk to
you about some I know you got boy ain't
got no [ __ ] blow I kept telling I
ain't got no blow and this is I got
something for you what do you got for me
I want to show you I'm gonna show and
then when we went back this years I've
nothing for you I just know you have
blow on ya I don't have no [ __ ] blow
I've known Irish since she first came
from Boston uh her name is Katie she's
[ __ ] nuts is that that waitress he
only had sex with black dudes that's it
oh no that's Katie she only has sex with
black dudes
she was the drunk and she was like they
they banned me from my showroom again
and you were just torturing her I have
the [ __ ] torture my job [ __ ] I didn't
I don't know I love Katie I seen Cave do
some crazy [ __ ] I seen the beat up a guy
once on the ramp yeah she remember daddy
like hey Katie remember the time you
beat the guy was like remember his pants
fell down oh my god she pulled him down
and threw him down and started hitting
her with his shoe and [ __ ] let me get
some shots real quick
hey man it's 2015 I love you guys more
than I did last year
dick Watanabe Jamie Stanley playing Air
writer
Frankie Nilson Mike Davis Jesse right
and the fake guy Dan I love you
[ __ ]
thank you for supporting and thank you
for being my [ __ ] quantum and
[ __ ]
so I got three more weeks in town to
relax and get my goals tighter and my
[ __ ] tighter for Buffalo in Columbus
yeah I'm in Buffalo this month I'm in
Columbus at the funny bone Superbowl
weekend two weeks later I'm in Austin
the Valentine's Day with uncle Joey
that's awesome and then the last week of
February and [ __ ] Indianapolis
like a [ __ ] excited about that
[ __ ] I want to talk to you cuz I went to
the store on Saturday with Paula and I
didn't I knew it but I didn't really
know is it till this weekend
you'll you'll do some of the same jokes
but your set is never the same and as
someone who doesn't do comedy like I
want and I saw a couple people there
Bobby Lee did amazing but there were a
couple people who did like the same
jokes have heard them do six months ago
at the store and it's just it does that
help when you're a comic or shouldn't
like if you're doing 15 new minutes
every night shouldn't it be different
like does it if you're doing the same
stuff does it not help well you're not
doing 15 new minutes every night what
you're doing is you're doing material
and you're trying your new stuff why
didn't winder than that okay that's what
I do that's what I think keeps the
audience coming back you know when I was
when I was a kid and I watched somebody
do TV I was hoping that they'd you know
do a certain joke that I wanted but also
something about some social commentary
something that they've seen some social
commentary of sorts that's it we've
discussed this a thousand times when I
see a comic doing the same act over and
over you're hurting my feelings because
you let me know you've seen nothing
interesting I see something [ __ ]
interesting every goddamn day yeah you
know but every room is different the
store that original room Ari and I had
this conversation on mushrooms Friday
night we were sitting there tormenting
[ __ ] people at the MGM Grand
sometimes you might write something
No and you might go up on stage
especially at the store and your goal is
not even to get laughter you just want
to try this [ __ ] joke off you just
want to try this [ __ ] joke up that's
it
but somebody before you does something
and now you have to call it like what
happened last week when I went down and
the music oh yeah that was BT Express
you know what are you gonna do
you killed I got off and you happy
everybody was happy but guess what the
[ __ ] joke I wrote that I worked for
[ __ ] a week I didn't get to try so
our people is shaking my hand oh man
that was a great set I'm thinking I suck
dick
I worked hard all [ __ ] week to try
that one line so sometimes you get
caught up in the energy of the room okay
so you forget [ __ ] you know I went to
the store last week I did the cocaine
joke or the cat yeah it just called fur
I know the audience and it calls for it
sometimes you might want to go up on
stage and have this but the audience
calls for something else is the audience
saying what material you saying no it's
just an energy in the room but it is
kind of crazy because the week before or
earlier that week I forget what it was
you had a not a great set at the store
like it was you just couldn't get them
on your side it was like a slow night
was it Christmas Christmas or Christmas
Eve of the main room the main Monday
night for the special show Monday night
was it yeah listen man you're gonna have
bad days gonna have good days it's just
knowing that inside that you gave it
your all that's the most important thing
even why starting to calm me I knew I
was a little older and I knew that
you're gonna have bad days and good days
the rule is that you went down there
showed up and gave it your all you
didn't get [ __ ] up you did what you
were supposed to do you took care of
business if I write and I work out in a
day I'm very happy the set at night is
to cherry on the [ __ ] Sunday yesterday
I had two things on my mind I wanted to
write a little bit and I wanted to work
out I had a tremendous work I've had a
great day of writing that's a good day
for man good day with my family i
sticked on my [ __ ] calories I can't
and I didn't do anything I didn't leave
the [ __ ] house basically left the
house maybe three I went to the farmers
market yesterday with the family walked
around
you're not banned from the promenade
band anymore and some people ask me oh
it's great to see you where you've been
I explain to them and they said
paparazzi's is still a lot to go you
know you just can't take pictures of the
kids I went over yesterday with mercy
and I put her in the foreign the petting
zoo and she didn't like the goats and
she didn't give a [ __ ] about the
chickens she liked the rabbit but after
a couple minutes just wanted to get the
[ __ ] out of there and I could see them
lurking and I'll tell you just seeing
them yes lay my blood pressure went up a
little bit but now I'm prepared if
anything ever happens and they follow me
my car now I'm prepared do they know
that one time I know that one time no no
they weren't taking picked dad nothing
to do with me right they were attacking
a guard that didn't need to be attacked
and all these [ __ ] little
testosterone [ __ ] [ __ ] father
Gentile [ __ ] were walking around on
that one person that's what my real true
feeling was to that farmers market that
I've helped out people doesn't even know
if I see somebody getting bullied or
something or something right I'll sit
there I won't say that I just sit down
watch for a few minutes to see where
this is going and that's what I did that
day but nobody did it to me and people
watched people were circling when they
had me surrounded I turned around one
time there was a ton of men with [ __ ]
little baby carriages and those Studio
City [ __ ] looking at me but nobody
did [ __ ] nothing and that's the
America we live in today sometimes you
get somebody with [ __ ] balls that
will stick up for the little guy
sometimes people won't even say no me I
see three people around one guy I got to
stop and just watch
I gotta stop and watch all threes are
not gonna jump you're not gonna jump
them you want to fight them individually
the guy did something to you you're
gonna fight him like a [ __ ] man but
all three is not on my [ __ ] watch and
not some guy that's a security guard on
a Sunday that's a short chubby guy that
doesn't even he's just doing this for a
[ __ ] job didn't even give him a water
gun you know and you guys want to be
tough guys around that's not gonna work
around me I was I wasn't raised that way
you stick up the little guy where at
least go hey man what the
[ __ ] there's four you [ __ ] here
really really pick one and fight them
what do you think and then you're gonna
have to fight one of them while the
[ __ ] fight one of them knock him in
the [ __ ] head and there none of these
three oh [ __ ] with you no more
and that's all my intention was but I
went yesterday everything was cool the
fish guy was cool and I got a couple of
Mexican [ __ ] fruit guys that love me
when I haven't got my back I told him so
that's it I spent some time with them
yesterday [ __ ] the wrath so any day I
work out right I spend my family I could
torture you on the [ __ ] phone I'm at
a complete Daly I thought we were doing
watch him this morning I know I know I
was lying I can't think I can't do it
dude what do you say to me come on man
well yeah you come on man come on man
it's gonna be bad cuz you call me more
like you call me like twice a day
usually maybe three times when it's like
four or five times with like once an
hour I know you have like a bad edible
in you or or or you're gonna go get
something terrible or it's just gonna be
a bad I went for the weed so yes I got a
couple of these stores I got a couple
grams of weed but then on the way out I
said let me get Billy a [ __ ] bang
bang I got a weak one but last night was
sitting me about seven o'clock I said
[ __ ] leak this thing myself
when I inhaled it and I got [ __ ] up
and I went to bed early I watched a you
Part two and I went the better that's it
I felt good the workout felt good
everything good I'm happy that uh we
made it through another years of podcast
and Matt happy that you guys are still
around thank you for all the love and
respect you give us and you know we try
hard and give you the same [ __ ] level
of respect as that's what we do here at
the church a [ __ ] what's
happened now also I want to put a
disclaimer out last week after the Vegas
show I talked to some people do not
[ __ ] please don't judge me on
whenever we talked about I was really
hiring the [ __ ] mushrooms in Vegas
and a bunch of people kept coming up to
me and talked on me and they didn't know
I was just freaking how that mushroom
was getting down inside and this one guy
came up to me and start asking me a
bunch of questions real sweetheart of a
guy with a beard and I looked him in the
face and I go what's with the [ __ ]
question shake my hand get the [ __ ] out
of here
and he just looked at me all weird I
didn't mean to say that it was just what
was cooking inside of me like stop with
the [ __ ] quiet you know if I came up
like what was in my mind yeah came out
of my mouth so please if I said
something to you off-color forgive me I
was just on mushrooms and you were in
front of me and I was freaking out well
mate are Ian Duncan kiss I love you guys
saw the pictures from Joe Rogan's
Twitter yesterday please go to Joe
Rogan's Twitter friend dinner and wrote
Duncan ass Rogen where we were sitting
and Duncan and we sitting right behind
me I got here the best seats in the
house and Duncan was great I'll start
throwing up the Illuminati figure and he
goes I've thrown up before and he's like
dump them what are you talking about so
Duncan went through his phone he does
look at the pictures of him with the
Illuminati people were taking pic this
is way before Saturday night show this
had been going on one time Duncan went
to a fight a month ago and he kept doing
the womanizing thing a signal so people
kept watching them they saw that Joe was
laughing his ass off you know with
loominatee were [ __ ] dying in the car
yeah you know and that was how it
started so I guess they went to the
fight and just took it to the next level
I didn't stay for the fight I had to go
I wanna show him my plate Sunday Monday
the right and get it all together to
have to go to a doctor and have a bunch
of paperwork for him I also looked at a
[ __ ] old Playboy I never look at
Playboy
you know yeah why are you looking at
playboy because the other day I was on
the computer and something happened I
typed in hay or something what the [ __ ]
was I doing I was looking for something
and I found our eonni nudes it said re
Olly nude pictures right I never saw our
really [ __ ] nude right ok so I clicked
on the [ __ ] Ariana nude pictures and
there was like 30 pieces Ariana nude
great to these beautiful face ugly is
[ __ ] a little [ __ ] you've ever seen
in your life
it just goes down flat like there's no
bump to it nothing it was bald which is
huh she's really skinny
yeah they put this non-existent you know
if you're gonna be a woman carry a lock
between your [ __ ] it's the ugliest
[ __ ] [ __ ] jersey flat the flat is
[ __ ] [ __ ] no hair
they just went backwards like it's a -
Buzzi like it went backwards like there
was no [ __ ] I mean I I know she hit
the Clinton [ __ ] but you could just see
it it's a downwards [ __ ] slope so I
was telling those guys at lunch ups and
they're like it's kind of ugly [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know let me read the sponsor -
get the [ __ ] out of here
like I was saying this morning it all
starts with on it you want it better
2015 you want to feel good about
yourself a [ __ ] the utmost optimum
optimization as they call it if you and
this isn't a vitamin or a supplement
this is a way of taking your [ __ ]
life to the next [ __ ] level whether
it's the the hemp for protein or it's
the [ __ ] strong bone which I use for
my knee and I'm getting great results
the shroom tech sport which I'll take
with me before I go to jujitsu today cuz
I haven't taken it a month you know I
don't just take the shroom text board
for everything I just take it for you
Jitsu just to give me some more
breathing and some more oxygen stuff I
love on I was at Aubrey the other night
and he was saying you know on it Aubrey
whatever warrior-poet unmad Flav was the
type of guy that whenever you talk to
him he's always looking for the next day
he's always going to these mountains
he's always going to these [ __ ]
things to find herbs and minerals and
it's just a constant search and that's
what on it's about it's a constant way
to be better he was so hard about going
back to Peru and he found this tea that
gets you you know it's just always
constant with it and that's why I
believe it on and that's why they
sponsor the podcast do me a favor go to
islet calm look at what the stuff they
have whether it's weights you know
kettlebells think if the battle ropes
all that [ __ ] I can't help you with the
10% off on the supplements you know this
do me a favor go to Hana calm just pick
something start with the [ __ ] alpha
brain put him on the Box Church church
and get 10% off start with that just do
me that favor tell her you want to make
new year's resolutions whether they're
[ __ ] or not you just want to start
today right 2015 you've been [ __ ]
around for too [ __ ] long go to Hana
calm today right now and get something
get a supplement I guarantee it's gonna
change your life you're gonna feel
better start with the alpha brain number
two my male favorite [ __ ] people in
the world Iron Dragon TV Dave Foley is
a helluva guy don't forget to go to box
what number today are one five four two
three I believe it's because Tim can
they'll be signing all the gas if you're
at the Consumer Electronic Show in Las
Vegas but anyway you put it I went back
on there again yesterday they've added
more movie sign dragon TV yeah like 30 a
month yeah like dirty a month do me a
favor view the classic martial arts or
you've heard about it you want to get
into it if if what's his name
Rodriguez's channel El Rey channel
doesn't have the martial art films you
want you know cuz my El Rey play some
great martial arts films on Friday night
Sam the whole Miami Vice things going on
right now if they don't have it on that
race don't get into these wait for
Friday night just whatever you want
[ __ ] it go to iron dragon TV pressing
the code name Joey and get two free
films on the [ __ ] arm just to get you
started trust me this is a company
that's growing getting better I think
they're adding something else and music
they don't [ __ ] around yeah I know Tech
doesn't [ __ ] around please go to high
end dragon TV today get two free rentals
my intro and what Joe and it's nanotech
the company the parent company they have
another channel where they're shooting
4k concerts it's really cool guys it
doesn't then get in with these guys
right now getting on this program you're
gonna love it
iron dragon TV and prescient Joey and
get two free [ __ ] rentals again Lee
was saying that's it it's here you've
been talking [ __ ] I gonna quit
smoking it's it started today it e-cigs
calm let me [ __ ] around go there right
now and press your luck Joey Church when
you get 20% off your first whether it's
your first electronic cigarette your
[ __ ] cigar
like I said 24 16 eight and zero you
could quit smoking in January be healthy
and not spit [ __ ] more clams in she
eat [ __ ] get that hand mixed with the
green spit you don't need that your life
no more quit smoking now go to hit
e-cigs calm this cigarettes come in
different flavors they taste good
they're smooth you can put it up in your
top pocket you could smoke in Vegas at
the [ __ ] blackjack table go ahead
e-cigs calm right now press Enter Joey's
Church and get 20 [ __ ] percent
off
whatever you want from their webpage
also my brother David up there and
[ __ ] nailed it live.com best vapor
put on the market somebody came to me in
Vegas and one like that and showed me in
the nail the life vapor pen tremendous
go to [ __ ] nail that life calm
impressing Joey Diaz and get 20% off
your first daughter something happens if
this baby pen
you called Dave boom the replacement
part is right there the next day
lifetime guarantee no [ __ ] around I'd
to thank nailed it life hit ecigs
dot-com I am dragging TV and on it for
back at us always and for starting a new
year up in us that's how we [ __ ] do
it [ __ ] beside that man it's up
to you this year it's up to you the
balls in your [ __ ] courts no more
[ __ ] around you want your life to be
better I can't help you Lee can't help
you Joe Rogan can't help you already
can't help you God can't [ __ ] help
you only you could [ __ ] help you grab
your [ __ ] balls
get a [ __ ] notebook and write down
what the [ __ ] you gonna do this year and
this is it you're not gonna have these
problems
[ __ ] the drugs [ __ ] the cigarettes [ __ ]
that dumb [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ]
today alright no more [ __ ] excuses
that's the [ __ ] this is the year of
the [ __ ] soldier it's 2015 we're
going in like [ __ ] Marines you
understand me 2015 we're getting back
what belongs us and that's it no more
[ __ ] around play the national anthem
Lee I'm sick of these [ __ ]
let's go the good one - which shoots and
[ __ ] people missing legs I want to
hit a good one Lisa yeah that's all
that's it it's over
alright never don't forget to go to on
it calm and he's covered see 10% off of
all the great supplements alpha brain
new mood zoom tech immune stream tech
sport anything like that use code word
Church okay at 10% off
go to iron dragon tv.com and these go
where Joey get two free rentals of all
the great martial arts movies Jackie
Chan it man series they have 4k
technology and if you're going to CES go
to the nano tech booth at one five four
two three Wednesday January 7th at 2
p.m. to meet Tim Kennedy go to hit ecigs
calm let's hit the letter e cigs calm
and use codeword Joey's church to get
20% off better tasting longer-lasting
the proof is in the vape easy cigarettes
and these cigars for you and different
levels of nicotine and go to nailed it
life calm and use code Joey Diaz no
spaces and you're gonna get 20% off of
the premiere vapor pen on the market for
the oil and wax voters out there
[Music]